foreign
digital marketing is the Beating Heart
of modern business strategies with
companies pouring billion of dollars
into digital advertising annually the
widespread adaption of digital
Technologies such as smartphones and the
internet has transformed how consumers
interact with Brands and make purchasing
decisions people not spend significant
Time online consuming digital content
and engaging with social media Platforms
in today's business landscape having a
robust digital marketing presence is not
just important but absolutely essential
it enables businesses to reach new
customers boost sales and establish
their brand online by effectively
connecting with their target audience
companies can stay ahead of the
competition and bring growth to their
businesses a few digital marketing
strategies include social media
campaigns search engine optimization
email marketing influencer marketing
content marketing and pay-per-click
advertising the digital marketing field
is experiencing rapid growth presenting
a wide range of career opportunities for
skill professionals common role in this
domain include digital marketing manager
social media manager SEO specialist
content marketing manager and email
marketing specialist individuals who are
passionate about harnessing the power of
digital channels to drive business
growth can look forward to exciting
prospects in this Dynamic industry based
on data from Glassdoor the average
annual salary for digital marketing
Professionals in the United States is
approximately one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in India the average
annual salary is 10 lakh prominent
hiring companies in the field of digital
marketing include VMware Infosys
Accenture ey Amazon Oracle Dell and
Linkedin this industry leading
organizations offer exciting
opportunities for professionals with
digital marketing expertise in order to
become a successful digital marketer it
is important to process the following
skills first it is essential to acquire
Proficiency in planning executing and
optimizing digital advertising campaigns
across us platforms such as Google ads
social media advertising and display
advertising next understanding SEO
principle including keyword research
on-page optimization and off-page
optimization techniques to improve
website visibility in search engine
results then it is crucial to focus on
the ability to create engaging and
valuable content that captivates the
target audience Drive traffic and
supports overall marketing objectives
then have a knowledge of effectively
managing and growing social media
platforms developing content strategies
engaging with followers and analyzing
social media metrics and then the
capability to analyze data from various
digital marketing channels extract
meaningful insights and make data driven
decisions to optimize campaigns and
Achieve better results additional skills
that are important to have an
understanding of include marketing
optimization digital strategy web
analytics communication and
collaboration developing their skills
combined with practical experience and a
passion for digital digital marketing
can pave the way for a successful career
in the field with that in mind if you
have a keen interest in digital
marketing and aspect to advance your
career in this field then enroll now in
the postgraduate program in digital
marketing a leading course in the world
offered by marketing land and search
engine Journal earn a prestigious
certification as a digital marketer from
Purdue University gain expertise in
website creation and promotion through
live Interactive Learning sessions
acquire comprehensive digital marketing
skills using Harvard Business publishing
cases engaging in 20 plus projects
leveraging chat deputy and AI tools and
exploring 10 plus real life cases and 35
Plus digital marketing tools this
comprehensive course offers a unique
blend of Life Interactive Learning we're
keeping you with both fundamental and
advanced knowledge to excel in your
digital marketing career as an added
bonus you will receive a valuable meta
certified digital marketing associate
exam Watcher worth USD 99 allowing you
to demonstrate trade your acquired
skills and expertise broadly as you
progress through the course you will
follow a comprehensive learning path
that includes various key areas such as
website creation exploring into Behavior
marketing search engine optimization
search engine marketing harnessing the
power of social media marketing and
unleashing the potential of email
marketing in addition this program
provides an array of elective options
such as blogging Affiliated marketing
B2B marketing and other exciting Avenues
to delve into this program covers a wide
range of valuable skills including
website creation Behavior marketing
keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing mobile marketing content
marketing and content strategy not only
the skills but it also covers tools and
Technologies such as SC ranking tag
Deputy Facebook LinkedIn YouTube Google
ads Google Keyword Planner YouTube
analytics Google Trends and many more
also in embark on exciting industry
projects that provide hands-on
experience and practical insights so
hurry up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced new success in
their career listen to their experience
find the simple learn Course Review Link
in the description box with this we have
come to the end of this best digital
marketing course for 2023. if you like
this video subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn if
you need any help opting for this course
please let us know in the comment
section below we will get back to you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here